sure you can do the plain vanilla point
spread the Patriots are favored by two
you can be in one of those box pools and
your office snooze here come the proper
what we like our the prop bets those
hundreds of offbeat bizarre propositions
we got these from bovada calm and online
sportsbook shuts katina for instance how
many times will the NBC announcers say
the words deflated balls the over/under
is three all right let's I'm taking it
over here taken over I think it should
be 30 I think I'm gonna hear it more
than three times okay then but maybe the
NBC guys are under orders not to say it
so it could be I don't know they could
be under orders now that's interesting
but if they don't say it and then cuz
you're courting controversy to leave
with Goodell the more you say it right
if they don't finish go back to foxridge
look like punks cuz the fact the matter
is for the last week all anyone has said
is deflated balls it is so they don't
say it on the big day they look like
they're they look like they're I just
think you like saying that word what
number do you figure it's two words so
you said the third race stephanie says
30 you he said no I said Sarah dirty I
say 20 20 okay going for 60 Jason Eric
Stephanie 30 2016 let's go to the next
one how many times will t be Tom Brady's
supermodel wife Gisele Bundchen he's
shown on TV the over/under is one and a
half okay there's no way it's gonna be
one and a half Giselle increases ratings
so half of Giselle okay there's no way
they're gonna show her all game long
she's gonna be out there or they're
beautiful kids looking fantastic they're
gonna show her 15 times do you think
she'll do hair and makeup before your
game you're just asking as a woman I
don't know where does hair and makeup
before he leaves his house of course oh
I see all right I'm gonna I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say aight aight just eight
times i say 15 what do you say 11 do you
not remember the last time you used in
the Super Bowl when they got her on the
way out of us and she had well maybe if
my husband could throw the ball and
catch the ball they would have won the
game that was a moat that went viral
they're gonna be okay so for the
superbowl advertising expert this one is
for you Jason way
what will Katy Perry be wearing when she
begins to halftime show pants shorts a
skirt or a dress I gotta go skirt there
I'm going pants because i actually think
unitard okay so you're going pan when
you said skirt yeah he said skirt at
least I hope I say pants I say shorts
sure it's